this year's Star Trek's 50th anniversary
and the latest Trek movie Star Trek
beyond comes out in July and tomorrow on
ET I will take you to the top-secret set
with Captain Kirk Chris Pine and the
rest of the Enterprise crew will we see
any cameos from the old crew well maybe
the original Captain Kirk can answer
that question
Carly Steele sat down with the one and
only William Shatner today to talk about
Star Trek enduring legacy the new movie
we were just on the set will you be
making an appearance no I am NOT where
you're not just on the set of the new
yes I wish them well JJ Abrams is a
genius the cast is wonderful but I know
nothing well mr. Spock I didn't know you
had it in you I'm frightened by how
little I knew then compared to what I
know now I wish that I knew a little bit
of what I know now welcome aboard
captain Williams close friend Leonard
Nimoy passed away last February Shatner
has a new book about their relationship
out next month how did you help
Leonard through some of his difficult
times we talked a lot we leaned on each
other's shoulder a lot through death
divorce
addiction Leonard opened up in
interviews about his battle with
alcoholism dating back to the second or
third season of Star Trek one day at a
time one day at a time one day any time
you found you were like a source of
strength for one another he was a source
of strength to me I only hope that I was
equal to what I saw from another
enduring legacy the music from the TV
shows and movies the Star Trek ultimate
voyage concert tour celebrates the 50th
anniversary I mean 50 years is a
phenomenon and it has never happened
before and in our lifetime it will never
happen again by the way the tour kicks
off tomorrow in West Palm Beach Florida
live long and prosper
look at you